All the peers in the UK, you got 6 days.
I'm calling you out to call out Chu Chu.
>> So, as you can see, Chu Chu has canceled
the event.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count brothers and
sisters and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
£500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, before we start, bro, just put
your hand on your head like this. Yeah.
And look at me.
>> I don't feel anything.
>> One more time.
>> No.
>> You need to trust the process, bro. You
just you want everything to happen so
fast. Yeah. I've already done it's going
to work. Jokes aside, guys, this is
Canyon Mims. Been spending the Okay.
Okay, we've been spending the last 10
days together. Alhamdulillah, a brother,
may Allah bless and preserve him in him.
May Allah guide his family to Islam and
mine as well. So, have you heard of the
church of Kai?
>> Just briefly, now that you've told me,
>> I'm not talking about myself, by the
way. I'm talking about this. He's he's
the actual guy.
>> I don't know anything about
>> nothing. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Besides, [laughter] you know what I like
when he does it? The echo.
>> And then the echo just goes through the
thing and you've got a group of people
holding their hands. Yeah. It's sad, but
he's taking advantage of other people.
Now, here's a video of what he actually
does. You ready? I'm ready.
Okay. What is your first reaction?
Obviously with me I want to you know you
see all them doing this.
>> I'm doing the same by like what the hell
are you guys doing in a different way?
Yeah. So
>> you are a Muslim for 2 years.
>> Yeah. Have you ever seen this? What do
you make out of it?
>> My first like reaction is how do we get
to a point where people just blindly do
things without questioning does this
have any basis in Islam? Like just like
what would you not think? Okay, let's
just like really quick ask some scholars
maybe like let me check if there's
anything in the hadith or Quran that
like says this is a real thing. Yeah.
>> But it just it just shocks me how many
people just blindly when they view
someone slightly as an authority they go
whatever they're saying is true.
>> Exactly. It goes back to ignorance and
desperation. This is wherehed
comes into play because is the oneness
of Allah and is having trust in the
process because what happens is people
become impatient. I want to marry
someone. I want to start a business. I
want this. I made dua. It's not
answered.
>> You have in Allah's plan. So when that
doesn't happen, they're like, okay, how
can I have a little loophole and get
this faster? I know I'll go to someone.
Apparently he's a peer. He can do it.
Now I want to also give praise to
someone that I you might not know but
his name ish Rashid. So he's someone I
have a little bit of differences with
when it comes to creed which let's make
that clear respectfully of course
there's nothing disrespectful my side to
him. He went and confronted him and I
have to praise him for this. Yes I
genuinely have to praise him for this.
We're going to play the clips inshallah.
He went in there and the guy ran for it.
Okay. So let's watch the video inshallah
and then we'll come and see what we can
learn from it. Before that though
Rashid. Yes. Alhamdulillah. Uh may Allah
subh bless him, guide myself and guide
him as well. Um he made a announcement.
He said look these peers peers are
people who they deem to be close to God
almighty. Okay. He said why are you guys
not coming out and talking out against
this fraud this fraudster. He was a clip
and they will go to him actually
confronting him.
>> All the bees in the UK up and down UK
all the bees all these guys all these
bees here in Birmingham and up and down
UK. You got six days. I'm calling you
out.
to call out chuk chuk be
there's peers who live around here
there's peers who live across there's
more be here than [music]
I'm telling you all to call out chof ch
Imagine 20 of you peers bothered to make
a one minute video warning all your
murids warning all your followers do not
go to this fraudulent ch but some of
them will never do it because they're in
the same business it's the same business
that is going ahead.
>> Chu chuff when he comes to the UK he
carries out gatherings which are
attended by hundreds of people who are
vulnerable and claims by standing up he
will blow down the microphone [music]
and people will be cured. This of course
is a scam. He is scamming the people and
misguiding the people. The cure for the
ailments of people is found in two
things.
One is medicine that people need need to
resort to medicine. medicine is from the
sunnah ofasam.
And secondly [music]
is the shifa found in alquran
and the sunnah ofam
as I mentioned earlier
and
but also simple remedies like the eating
of the drinking of zum zum water
and those foods which are beneficial and
nutritious and abandoning ing unhealthy
lifestyle.
>> That was a clip of him
>> talking about, you know, warning and
saying that this guy's a fault. The next
clip of is of him actually going to the
place and confronted a guy. Let's watch
that.
>> So, as you can see, Chu Chu has canceled
the event. Uh, alhamdulillah.
Um, he ran away as expected.
So, inshallah maybe another day. We're
currently being escorted out by the
police.
>> So, you can see he's gone there. Now,
Allah tells us in the Quran,
meaning come together against
righteousness. What that means is that
if we see an oppression being taken
place to any community, be it the Jews,
be the Christians, be the um Hindus,
whatever it is, be it with people with
differences, we should come together
against that evil. And there was
something called hil that happened at
the time of the prophet Muhammad before
Islam in that sense. Yeah. Where a man
was oppressed and he called out and said
who in to the pagan Arabs he was calling
who will come to my aid and give me
justice. The prophetam went and helped
that man to get justice for him. He was
owed money.
>> And then afterwards the prophetam said
if this situation happened at Islam I
would have done the same thing. Meaning
what? That he would have joined forces
with the idol worshippers against the
oppression. Yeah. So here as you can see
he's come together uh well he's gone
there to confront this man and say that
he's a fraud. Yes. So which is
important. So something that you might
not know we can come together with
Christians, Jews, whoever it is. If an
attack happens on an innocent place
whatever [snorts] it is we are told in
our religion we can come together with
these individuals and speak out against
it. Now so can you just punch me in the
mouth? Well I will forgive him for the
sake of Allah. I'm joking. Sorry guys.
[laughter]
Send me location. So in a nutshell um
he's done that. Now the thing is this
obviously I want to praise him and I'll
be honest with you if I think you would
have joined me as well. If he was to
tell us listen we're going to go
confront this guy we would have joined
forces. Do you see what I'm trying to
say? Cuz at the end of the day you can
clearly see it's fraud and I think
>> is he charging for these events?
>> Yes.
>> So it's a full grip.
>> He's probably trying it's truth.
>> He is he must be. And the funny thing is
all these people that you see they're
not in Pakistan. They're in the UK.
>> These are people in the west. Yeah. who
are going and believing this nonsense
because of superstition.
>> It's a it's a really sad example of a
lack of faith in Allah, right? Where you
are, like you said, you're so desperate
to where you feel you need to search for
answers outside of the fold of Islam.
It's like if you have a problem, you
should know Islamically there are
solutions to your problem, right? Like
maybe get back on your five daily
prayers before you try to go hear
someone goof.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And the thing is
they don't do this. Many people come to
me, brother, I can't find someone to get
married, brother, this is what happened.
I ask a similar question. How's your
relation with salah? Um, and I'm like,
the audacity, you don't even pray your
basic salah and you want, do you think
it's Amazon Prime? Like, I make order, I
make a dua, and it comes tomorrow. What
do you think this is? You need to trust
Allah's process. And the thing is, you
make dua, dokar, and regardless, you
should be praying without expecting
anything from Allah. your prayer and
your good deeds and what Allah tells you
to do is not conditional to what Allah
does. We worship Allah because of who he
is, not because of what he does for us.
And I want to give I want to praise Yes.
As somebody who some people call me
whatever it is like I don't call this
names and things etc. Do you get it? I
follow. Alhamdulillah. And even him how
he was so respectful with people that he
differed with. Okay, we do have our
differences with Rashid and respectfully
he's someone that's older than me and
senior in in knowledge and I would
always have utmost respect for him even
though we have our differences but I
have to give praise where praise is due
and I salute him for this and not that
he needed me. If I knew he was going
there I would have joined hand to hand
with him. Yes. Okay. And even when it
comes to someone coming to Islam, if
somebody like obviously uh with their
with their ideology, it's it's different
to ours. But the thing is I would prefer
if somebody came and said to me um I
follow us. They're called Asharies.
Yeah. Okay. If someone said to me, I'm
either going to become an ashar or I'm
not accepting Islam. I say, "Oh, do you
have to become ash? I rather you become
an ashari." Yes. Who has certain beliefs
and negates certain attributes of Allah,
whatever it is for that matter, then you
become like disbeliever. I prefer that.
And that is how it should be. So we give
praise where it's due. However, one
thing I do need to mention which is
important as well is that Assari and
also the creed that he follows they are
open to um this thing of peers. So this
man has taken advantage of that. Yeah.
But it just shows you the dangers when
you open that door you have frauds like
this person who comes out and says yeah
I've been chosen by God and when I do
you know they exploit it. That's why the
the theology that we follow, the creed,
we don't have these issues because we
cut that by saying, listen, do we
disagree that there are people who are
close to God? Of course not. That people
are righteous, of course not. However,
we want to close the doors to fraudsters
like this. I mean, that's all I can say.
Again, big praise to Shakat Rashid for
doing what he did and calling out the
people in the community. You have to
give credit where credit's drew. Any
last words on you?
>> I would say from a reverse perspective,
always have a healthy hesitance of what
people are saying, right? because
everyone's going to say things and a lot
of people don't have the knowledge of
what they're saying. So like someone
will like try to correct me on the basic
things. I'll just go, okay, can you show
me where in Islam that's from? And I
think that's a good application of
everything is always do your own
research. Always go okay, where is this
person's knowledge from? Where is their
authority from? Where do they have the
credibility to say what they're saying?
And then once you find out then they
have the credibility, yes, listen to
them. Or you find out they don't and
don't listen to them.
>> Exactly. And that's where it goes. It
goes back to the Quran and Sunnah,
brothers and sisters. That's what it is.
I personally, and I want to end on this.
Do I believe our ashari brothers and
sisters have ill intentions? No. I
genuinely believe she assar and those
who follow that creed asharis I believe
they have sincere intention of praising
Allah and want to glorify Allah. That's
why they have the differences with us.
And it's the same thing with us. Even
though we believe the intentions are
there but it's not according to the
sunnah from our theology but again the
intentions that they want goodness and
they want to praise Allah to the highest
degree. It's still there. And we from
our creed as well is the same. We want
to praise Allah and glorify him and
affirm his attributes the way he's
affirmed for himself that be his hand
yet the way it be his majesty. We affirm
that. So I just want to say that
inshallah and that's it. And brother
Ken, we're going to say goodbye to him
today. He's going to Indones um
>> Indonesia.
>> Indonesia it is inshallah. We ask Allah
to protect him and allow him to be a
means that he serves Islam and brings
many people to Islam. Inshallah. We ask
Allah to protect brother Canyon and many
revers like him from wasw was from the
evil and don't for morning evening.
Yeah. What what app using for that salah
pro because he's a pro. Till next time.